I
miss you I love you Mommy
this is a scene where Amy is home and
Aisha does not know that she's home from
work and she stumbles across Aisha
feeding her daughter African food
Senegalese food in particular
when Aisha has been allowing Rose to eat
this food because it's what
Rose prefers and Amy walks in on Rose
having lunch and is very upset by the
fact that her daughter is eating this
food that she deems as less than what
are you feeding her I didn't know you're
here
that's not what I asked you
I worked so hard
so hard
and the one time I come home sick
I find you feeding my daughter's food
that is way too spicy for her tummy
what is even in this
what if she's allergic
nikiatsu was so supportive of us to just
find the authenticity and and the truth
of each of the moments so I just
approached it in a really grounded way
cognizant of where Aisha is in the
script and that it is a very evolved
place from where she started as an actor
when you're studying or doing script
analysis one of the things you notice is
who in the scene is really pushing it
Forward
um at least at the very top of it and
that's Michelle because she comes in so
hot so upset and all I really had to do
was respond to that in kind with the um
understanding of Aisha's power and where
she's at in this moment so between
Aisha's power and Michelle's power you
just have these two women that uh go at
it
when I did come around the corner I
think I probably shocked Rose a little
bit
it was uncomfortable it was
uncomfortable for for me to have that
kind of aggression
these were the takes where Rose our
child actress had no idea what was going
on Michelle is so good at being unhinged
it's so fun to watch her play with
tension and with Rising rage the subtext
is all of these class dimensions
privilege allows you to be blind to
certain nuances how is this nanny
feeding my child I have this specific
food that's really organized and Bland
and soulless kind of like the condo
itself and kind of like Amy's marriage
since I've started
I have been buying her food or making
some of my own
are you too busy to get as an actor it
always makes me nervous because I wasn't
quite aware of what emotionally I might
do because this was I think the final
scene actually that we shot in the
relationship and so uh it was the
culmination for me as well in terms of
the Arc of the character and so I'd been
building into it and emotionally I've
been building into it
acting is very physical for me and so it
was important for us to utilize the
space the kitchen island I wanted to get
across that Island as an actor you know
I wanted to be in her face and I
couldn't and it was separating us as
disconnected as they were physically
there were probably more connected and
really seeing each other for who they
really were it's a very confrontational
scene Amy's very much taken aback
because it's the first time that she
Witnesses Aisha really stepped into her
power my overtime hours
did you subtract the hours you spent
losing track of my daughter my dime is
not free at this point Aisha has been
experiencing these Supernatural events
Aisha starts to act out in ways that are
much more rebellious this is
a nanny's talk so do mothers
I am my mother too
Rina Yang is our DP and Niki yatsu who's
adamant about hiring a DP that
understood black skin and that could
light it well and she did she executed
it beautifully I've never been lit like
this
we shot two cameras one was on Rose a
child actor and the other one would be
either on Amy or she's just trying to be
as invisible as possible with a camera
and Lighting in the way that we just
wanted to capture the energy of the
actors we talked a lot about color
palette of Amy's condo on Aisha's home
trying to differentiate the world in
Aisha's home which is more kind of
spontaneous and warm and handheld and
then Amy's world is a bit more
controlled and you know we would shoot
on a dolly and you know a bit more
considered composition and camera
movements everything in the frame in the
condo is speaks to Amy and Adam's
lifestyle but also speaks to a specific
color palette the blues are very
lagoon-like they speak to the water
Motif I need an overnight from you
tomorrow no I need to get out of here I
need to get away I can't think of this
overpriced shoe box so seven to seven
150 flat rate is very reasonable to 50.
you drive a very hard bargain in advance
more open when you have a woman-led set
you know you can kind of like lean in a
little bit more it's sort of just sort
of this welcome energy that feels very
inclusive nikkiatsu's Talent as a writer
and as a Storyteller she has an
incredible capacity to write complex
characters that are also nuanced that
say a lot in between the words
yes I'll be back okay God exists as many
things as mothers as lovers as workers
as survivors as people that contain
multitudes as we all do but it's
difficult to write and it's difficult to
execute my favorite moment in in the
movie actually is um the scene that
takes place right after the
confrontation in the kitchen which is
when Anna looks into the actual cameras
that have been watching her the whole
time and she turns it on them and she
actually looks straight into the camera
and that moment is so so powerful for me
thematically this is a really emotional
moment for me to to witness
what it meant to the story but as an
actor it was uh it was just a moment of
awe for me
I wanted to see something that felt like
it explored the American dream but also
was specific to the African immigrant
experience I just hope that people see
domestic workers around them and people
who are marginalized with fresh eyes